hello welcome to new rockstars my name
is Sam basher and this has been an
awesome few weeks for superhero fans not
only did we get a new trailer for
Captain Marvel and Avengers endgame in
not only are we getting the first Miles
Morales spider-man and Aquaman movies
but we also got another ambitious
crossover from the CW arrowverse
Elseworlds
in this crossover we saw arrow Supergirl
and flash come together to take on John
degan and the monitor and stop a reality
warping world ending event and only that
but we also saw our first crossover with
Superman Lois Lane John Wesley Shipp
splash from the 90s flash show and bat
woman OH
confirming the existence of Batman in
the CW universe I mean he's been teased
but now it's all 100% oh we got him gang
now there are even more juicy east
breaks and hidden references within this
crossover that may have slipped by you
so let's not dilly-dally and hop into
this breakdown
oh these three episodes spoiler warning
of course for all these shows all DC
shows movies comics and I don't well
spoiler warning I like you tella eating
out of the jar and I once saw see Thomas
Howell in an elevator at Comic Con he
was very nice
let's get these Easter eggs since most
of them are from comic books we're just
going to go episode by episode starting
with part 1 and this is the Flash's
episode how exciting we open on earth 90
the home of John Wesley ship's Barry
Allen which is a fun nod to the flash
series that aired in 1990 we also got a
bit of his theme at the end of the scene
we're like a little second and litter
throughout this stat we'll ground if you
will our other heroes of note you see
star girl firestorm a captain or citizen
cold you can see a vixen you can see the
race helmet at least one of the Hawks
probably Hawkman and there are a few
more but most importantly it looks like
we can see the green arrow from the
Smallville universe based on the lime
green coloring of his suit not the only
Smallville mod when we get in these
episodes no siree Bob
here we're introduced to the monitor The
Watcher over all of the multiverse and
the CW multiverse the keeper of the book
of destiny now the book of destiny could
be a nod to the destiny of the endless a
member of the endless and DC Comics that
carries around a similar book as for the
monitor his first appearance was in the
New Teen Titans vol 1 number 21 in July
of 1982 he is key during one of the
biggest events in DC Comics history the
crisis on infinite or more on that later
asked for his powers is basically
limitless he's never really been tested
and his time in comics was a pretty
short-lived we
me Jeremy Davies aka dr. John degan one
of our big bads
for this crossover of comic book fans
should be more familiar with dr. destiny
his supervillain persona also his new
look at the end of this crossover as
closer to his comic book appearance in
the new 52
dr. destiny stick if you will is that he
can manipulate people's dreams at least
it's been narrowed down to that as of
late he's actually a star of one of my
favorites Justice League episodes from
when I was a kid
he's one scary dude possibly getting his
name because of the book of destiny that
he's using to rewrite all of reality
probably good job Sam moving into the
current crisis you probably noticed the
red skies is a big nod to two things one
of them being that in most crises in DC
Comics the sky goes red and we get
yellow lightning storms cool but also
since we find out that the flash from
Earth 90 is trying to reach out to our
boys because this be a nod to his color
scheme I'm just spitballing here after
Oliver gets his new speed powers he
scoots his way over to Ivo Labs where he
accidentally unleashes the Android Amazo
a popular comic book villain for the
Justice League if that was able to
recreate the powers of the Justice
League just by looking at him this boy
is a big time heavy hitter which I'm
very glad we're finally able to see his
real robot form because dr. Ivo actually
made an appearance way back in the
flashbacks in season two of arrow and
the name of Mesa was actually connected
to the ship that Ivo owned to get to
Lian Yu and since the androids powers
are mirakuru based like the Deathstroke
serum it all became connected does it
make sense doesn't really matter cuz it
was awesome next let's give a shout out
to them explaining where the prisoners
pooped in those science cells at STAR
Labs but more importantly let's get to
the my first big smile during this
crossover the transition to Smallville
on earth 38 with save me by Remmy zero
aka the Smallville theme song aka the
best theme song of all time also that's
the same farm from Smallville TV show
who have a happy boy happy boy here we
get the first glimpse of our new Lois
Lane who is great by the way all soaring
a bit of purple like she does in the
comics and the Superman in animated
series also their relationship seems an
awful lot like the classic Superman
relationship between Lois and Clark
which don't worry there are plenty of
references to the classic Superman films
coming out very shortly there's also
reference to the jeweled mountains of
Krypton on Argo city which is from the
comics which is this right now little
rock that just floating on space also if
that drawing that all
of deacon and the watcher looks familiar
that's because it was done by none other
than be one and only Jim Lee a popular
DC Comics artists actually the head of
DC creative right now love his art style
and nearing the end of the first episode
we hear a shout out to Wade and Agustin
who are both of iris of DC Comics Mark
Waid being the famous writer who gave us
some of the best flash stories and Brian
Agustin working on Gotham by Gaslight
one of the first Elseworlds stories from
DC Comics the first if I'm not mistaken
also the final shot the episode has
Batwoman on top of a building in Gotham
looks a lot like central city but also
this looks a lot like an homage to the
intro to batman the animated series a
bingo moving on to part two that would
be arrow chatter the new intro with
Grant Gustin playing Oliver Queen and we
get a return of Cain Wolfman aka Ravan
sharply this is the handle he's going by
aka Deathstroke son fun fact became part
of his first name as a reference to Bob
Kane one of the creators of Batman and
Marv Wolfman the creator of Deathstroke
when my favorite writers of all time and
it's amazing that Batman is acknowledged
at all in this episode but it's great
that Oliver doesn't believe in him
calling him an urban myth concocted by
the Gotham City police to scare
criminals I mean arrow has to be the
original vigilante of course amazing and
like I said this isn't the first
reference to Batman in the CW universe
but still incredible also shout-out to
Vesper Fairchild Oliver's contact in
Gotham and previous lover it's actually
a Batman character Batman actually slept
with her and her life in comics was
pretty short lib she was there and we
get a fun not to Christopher Nolan and
Tim Burton when you hear the
intersections of two streets CW loves
doing that corner of Nome and Burton
Nolan and Burton also it's interesting
that we find out that Bruce Wayne and
Batman have been missing for three years
that man has been known to go missing in
the comics he even takes breaks
occasionally which he should because his
life seems awful also when we walk into
Wayne tower we see some vines and that
Plaza could this be a nod to poison ivy
possibly by the way I know they shot
some of these scenes in Chicago much
like the Nolan films more references to
come and shout out to Batman 66 and the
red button hidden under the bust of
Shakespeare and the Wi-Fi password being
Alfred also it seems like the CW shows
can literally show you everything from
Batman's history except for Batman also
it's so weird that Batwoman and
Supergirl are cousins of Batman and soup
should that mean that Korra knows that
Batman is Bruce Wayne I can't really get
into it right now because there's too
many references but think about it but
back to earth 90 flash for a second this
feels an awful lot like that flash
vision from BVS when you know you see
John Wesley Shipp popping through that
little dimensional hole now we're into
the Batman Easter eggs like the cold
villains and Arkham supercool but let's
give a shout out to all the villains
were able to see Cobblepot oh that is a
horse the penguin you have eyes Lee P
for Pamela that's poison ivy see she
came back round Carlo B or basil that's
the original Clayface and you have nygma
e for Edward nygma aka the Riddler and
of course the last most famous
Guggenheim am the creator or one of the
creators of the arrow burrs we also see
a glimpse of psycho-pirate he plays a
big role in this crossover now
psycho-pirate is a character created by
Marvel funny who plays a huge role in
crisis on Infinite Earths we also meet
Nora fries wife of Victor fries who
looks like she's recovered from her
condition from the comics and from
Batman the Animated Series also we get a
nod to the known vers Bane's mask you
can see from Dark Knight Rises right
there on the Shelf man what a good get
also if you notice in this scene above
you'll see the date in 1994 above Nora
when she's working on the freeze gun a
nod to Batman Forever 's release date
probably I think we then get our first
look at bat woman in action she's
extremely capable and in the middle of
all this we could get a reference to dr.
crane a a scarecrow and his fear toxin
infecting both Oliver and Barry and
bringing out their own worst fears for
each other Malcolm Merlyn and
reverse-flash
ooh boy but to cap off this episode we
get a nod to world's finest the comic
named for the team-up of Batman and
Superman which is amazing now Supergirl
on Batwoman and on to our next big smile
moment for Sam when John Wesley Shipp
finally appears on earth one confirming
that he is Barry Allen from the 90s show
and that in his world there is a Green
Lantern Jon Stewart and he's played by
John Diggle confirming kinda in a way in
a roundabout way a fan Theory from a few
years ago saying that John's middle name
is Jon Stewart Diggle and that he would
get a Green Lantern ring eventually next
we get confirmation of something even
worse on its way hinting to crisis on
Infinite Earths officially the big
crossover we've been waiting for but to
end this episode reduce to the trigger
torrents Barry and Oliver's new personas
who are twins and DC Comics who become
bank robbers really nothing else to say
there
and we get to see the black suit
Superman but now on to part three
Supergirl
we find out the deacon has rewritten
reality and made himself Superman on
earth one shout out to STAR Labs finally
being a connected piece of the Superman
lure STAR Labs actually was originally
from the Superman comics so yay for
being his base of evil and shout to Gary
from legends of tomorrow as our
bartender at our evil bar and loved
seeing Jimmy Olsen as Superman's worst
pal which is a flip on him being his
best friend in the comics so cool also
worth throwing out that bringing over a
Superman from another universe to fight
an evil Superman is a page out of
injustice which I am not upset about and
justice is one of the best stories DC is
made in forever but buckle up kids here
come your references to the original
Superman movie like B characters running
around the world to stop time doesn't
really make sense but doesn't matter
also here's a nod to crisis on Infinite
Earths with very running around the ANSI
monitors weapon and then thawing but it
also we almost lost Cara - which we
originally did in prices on Infinite
Earths but back to Superman references
we see Clark sitting down a helicopter
safely like he did in the original
Superman movie but the references don't
stop there for Superman films you get a
little nod I think - Man of Steel with
the whole almost neck snapping thank God
that would have been weird but moving
forward we see all of our bargaining
with the monitor and it feels very
reminiscent of other comic book events
but for me seemed a lot like Tony Stark
drunkenly yelling at Odin to allow him
to make guru armor or the Avengers
pretty cool
but also shout out to Lois hammer which
could be a nod to Steel's hammer in the
comics but then we officially get a look
at dr. destiny and boy he's gross
SuperDuper gross but what's not gross is
the acknowledgment that possibly we
could be getting a John Kent in the
future aka Superboy from DC rebirth I'm
a big fan of the character and I hope we
maybe it's some form of them but if we
don't I get it but pretty excited about
this also I'm a big fan of Lois and
Clark finally getting hitched we
probably won't see that wedding on any
of these shows but if we do I'll be
happy but again another big shout out
the classic Superman films with Clark
crushing the coal to make a little
diamond and Lois's outfit in the
fortress of solitude and as we get to
the end of this crossover it seems kind
of clear that Oliver must have
sacrificed his own life possibly down
the line we'll have to wait till next
year
just like psycho pirates fate cuz he
doesn't seem like he's doing too well
with Doctor
there you hear him say world's will live
world's will die and nothing will be the
same which is pulled directly from
crisis on Infinite Earths which is
teased to be coming fall 2019 that's
very exciting guys what other references
did y'all catch where was noir in this
episode did John do anything is John
wisly ships flash dead cuz it seems like
it
we'll find out more next year let me
know which of these references were your
favorite and which of those Gotham
inmates you'd like to see in a Batwoman
series boy howdy I'm excited for that be
sure to LIKE share and subscribe to new
rock source for more and follow me at
Sam basher and I'll see you guys next
time